these aren't nests they're waste dumps
for a truly monster tunneling project
a termite Mega City the size of Great
Britain
it dwarfs any City that humans have ever
built it's mind-boggling
analysis suggests that every year the
insects here excavate over 50 million
tons of soil
the amount that's been moved around to
build these tremendous Mounds is the
equivalent of 4 000 Great Pyramids of
Giza this is a huge structure built by
tiny insects soil analysis confirms some
of these insect Mounds are 4 000 years
old
built more than 2 000 years before the
rise of the Roman Empire
and the excavation that produced them is
the most extensive bioengineering effort
by a single insect species anywhere on
the planet
this is actually a mega City